former Vice President Joe Biden had
another Super Tuesday and expanded his
lead in the Democratic presidential race
Biden won in at least four of the six
states which voted yesterday with two
states too close to call
he took the battleground state of
Michigan by double digits Biden now
leads the race by 150 delegates which
significantly narrows any path to
victory for senator Bernie Sanders and
Oh Keith is in Cleveland Ohio and our
what are we hearing from the Sanders
campaign now well good morning Anthony
Sanders and Biden were both scheduled to
hold events here in Cleveland last night
but canceled them amid concerns in this
state about the virus outbreak Sanders
went home to Vermont we've yet to hear
from him but one of his prominent
supporters called it a tough night turns
out Democrats are still looking for that
candidate they believe can defeat
President Trump and more of them believe
it's Joe Biden it looks like we're gonna
have another good night addressing staff
in Philadelphia last night Joe Biden
said that going forward his campaign is
about party unity and I want to thank
Bernie Sanders and his supporters for
their tireless energy and their passion
we share a common goal and together
we'll defeat Donald Trump Biden was
lifted by high voter turnout in Michigan
where nearly 1 million people voted
absentee almost twice as many as in 2016
the former vice president claimed
victories yet again with the backing of
African American voters but also thanks
the white voters and labor union members
earlier in the day touring an auto plant
in Detroit Biden had a testy exchange
with the voter over gun rights
[Music]
that's important second
fire that's not free speech
went on to say that he proposed taking
away semi-automatic weapons also for the
first time both the Biden and Sanders
campaigns called off planned rallies in
Ohio because of the corona violence
whenever we do rallies we consult with
public health officials because the last
thing in the world we will ever want to
do is put anybody in danger the crisis
could be a boost for Biden standing our
exit poll found that Democratic voters
overwhelmingly believe the former vice
president is best equipped to deal with
a major crisis like this coronavirus
outbreak Michelle Thank You ed